tende a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo super
noi axon ai ragazzi un rpg horror che
erano un casino di tempo che non ne
facevo un rpg horror sarebbe tipo mentre
father il museo voglio assolutamente
farlo così come voglio fare anche molti
altri però comunque è una roba che non
faccio nome po di tempo quindi è un
genere un po diverso per quelli che si
sono iscritti recentemente perché io ho
tempo fa li faceva anche questi tenterò
di giocare anche questo anche perché
sono tipo le tipo mezzanotte 40 quindi
sono proprio contento di rigiocarla a
quest ora se allora partiamo perché
sennò iniziano titolato lo sfondo è
bellissimo che tipo di un gran figo
sono passati tre anni da quando mia zia
è morta a casale quelle menti sono
voluta andare nella casa che lei ha
trascurato dopo che è morta perfetto la
è andata a casa solo perché deve vedere
mettiamocelo un po d'olio st porta
questo posto e polveroso è dovrebbe
esserlo visto che è stato abbandonato
per tre anni che sono tornato nella casa
di mia darò un'occhiata in giro per la
casa ben andiamo in giro qua fuori sta
tornando a casa mia perfetta devo fare
di preciso devo controllare a casa dimmi
questa nella casa di mia zia perfetto e
cosa perché fontegrossa sa casadio mio è
un h cos'è lo voglio anch'io sto posso
permettere la playstation ma tipo del
raggio sa cosa non dovevo pensare questa
cosa la meglio se me ne stavo zitto non
la diceva sta cosa prova marina a casa
comunque mi piace
vabbè erba del vicino è sempre più verde
ma in questo caso ci vuole poco è perché
vince trascuratissimo una lavatrice un
pozzo
vabbè up artist di sopra a seconda anche
di sovrastato questa è chiusa dice
quante grossa sta a casa regala
l'atmosfera è strana perché c'è storia
logiche continua a fare il clac clac
dalle 14 ora questa cosa non l'ho capita
comunque ho controllato tutti
telefono che squilla dove c'è una casa
enorme come lo trovo un telefono michela
mio paese avrebbero attaccato 14 volte
già e non è per dire ecco ma [ __ ]
pronto pizza chi è o mickey è mia madre
come auto nuove a casa ma che nuova casa
è molto polverosa ma molto grande
fantastica il tuo bagaglio dovrebbe
arrivare domani grazie posso chiedere
una cosa
ciao ciao mamma perfetto la chiamata la
mamma la sera l'abbiamo fatta prima
della dormire è tardi dovrei fare una
doccia andrà a dormire si sia però io
non mi sarei trasferito nella casa di
tua zia morta che problema è al cervello
fatti sta cazzo di doccia per dormire e
il doccia sexy ragazza però dormire
nella stanza degli ospiti questa nota
nella stanza degli ospiti al piano di
sopra va bene stanza degli ospiti
sei stato questo rumore non lo so zia
però non mi è piaciuto manco per il no è
semplicemente caduto appendiabiti sì
però non è una chiave ormai andiamo a
dormire domani vediamo dove diavolo
entrasse chiaro che regga ci siamo ne
vado a dormire ci va beh ma chi se ne
frega basta che dormi ho trovato una
chiave in un appendiabiti a caso voglio
capire dove potrei mai andare a ficcare
sa chiave forse me la fico io ti sei
pisciata nel letto 0 cos'è sta
gocciolanti se io sentissi una roba del
genere a casa mia cambierà
cribbio cazzo non me l'aspettavo so cosa
ne è un brutto sogno molto su qualcuno
ha pisciato la voce impedisco a
ricordare senti me lo ricordo io e
questa mi deve bere durante la notte in
cucina per che cosa
cosa è successo non so cosa ho cliccato
sono dei cappelli nei lavandini al mio
dio capelli come è possibile che siano
usciti dal lavandino sono usciti i
capelli lavandino
devo dare un'occhiata all'acqua domani
ok dove solo dormire adesso va col cazzo
che dormi coi capelli nel lavandino zia
io non so se c'è i mostri nei tubi frega
niente l'importante è sentito ho sentito
qualcosa sì ho sentito anch'io zia e
dove ho sentito sto rumore e brutte era
di sopra
non so sentite ragazzi andiamo a dormire
sia la porta si è aperta la porta
no è no beta ammazzo il figlio going
stay out going dai facciamo
sono curioso qualcuno ha pisciato sotto
la sedia o ha pisciato la sedia non sono
alleno non mi interessa andiamo a
dormire per l'amor di dio
chiudiamo e mi aveva sete bastardi cosa
cosa cosa qualcuno caschi ha fatto la
merda e pescando nelle pozzanghere per
terra non mi riesco a muovere o cazz o
giorno è nè ascolta a sole 4 di notte se
hai voglia di dormire e dormo anch'io no
chi sei tu che spiega si muore si muove
cosa ascoltami mikita castam in chiave
veloce entriamo sta venendo verso di me
sì e io entrare io è infra red c'è una
faccia che appare mi sta dando fastidio
mentre tenta enzo nella porta di dio ai
have to get away brava brava io metterei
dei tavoli da come non detto
e davanti a me devo correre dove posso
nascondermi non lo so zia però la fuga
continuerà finchè non troverà il posto
giusto dove nasconderti ma che roba
orribile di omino già posso fare gatte
la posso fare
cioè la porta con le mani devi startene
fermo che ti denuncio game over perfetto
ragazzi è stato bellissimo
ho perso come l'ho data a no dario
rifarmi tutto daccapo ma [ __ ]
ragazzi ci sono sti sussurri di che mi
stanno facendo cagare in mano ci sono
andato addosso come un deficiente ho
sbagliato io voglio ragazza notte ve lo
dico non dormo un cazzo ve lo dico a
prescindere quanto corre mio dio nella
doccia e la doccia la cena che si muove
con lo schifo come faccio come faccio
spiegatemelo
sei stronzo come posso dove rega non lo
so nell'armadio sì che che botta di culo
assurdo ha preso non ho qui da qualche
altra parte
l'importante che non vi abbia prendo mi
ha ucciso il possibile mai che io
l'unica porta [ __ ] dove nel camino
davvero massei servono tanto mi trovo
sono convinto da culo lo sapeva e la
roba indigente mai tanto si guarda anche
dentro le piastrelle minazione mi sto
pagando addosso a casa mia
ancora co sto qui harting la fai
se cioè la era giusto era armadio si sia
lodato il sole what is money si è
mattina mattino bra esci da st cazzola
mi sono addormentata come il fatto hanno
tormentarti nell'armadio con quei
cristiano lì fuori hai dei problemi
fatelo dire ti sei fatto colazione sia
devi scappare devi buttarti la vedi la
finestra ti devi buttare fuori di testa
è veramente mi sono nascosto al city 6
nascosta nell'armadio e ho trovato una
chiave ieri dovevo capire che cosa apre
ascoltami by fuori dalle palle
c'è ma vi sembra il caso legato a eccola
perfetto per questo qua e là mi chiami
ricorda in psicosi
apriti blair link ma che anche allora
sentite che che diavolo distanze sono
c'è qualcosa nello specchio sono con
milano c'è una nota le cose belle sono
fatte per nascondere qualcosa qui la
henin che senza questo guarda dietro a
che cosa fino che a madonna che bel
mattino ragazze sole che splende la vita
di tutto questo questo cliccato se sono
artificiali cosa ai fiori big bang
tirati fuori tira fuori fiori sono dei
fiori artificiali non me ne frega un
bene però mica c'è un sole che spacca le
pietre giuro una chiave sopra
eccola perfetto tanto è tutto qua alla
fine che funziona perfetto è bella con
un armadietto scolastico un'altra chiave
ma bastano se chiama maga le chiavi mi
stanno sul culo o a notte
io le ore stanno provando ad
intrappolare mi loro mi odiano se io non
riesco a proteggermi la password saeki
un sicuro di non dimenticarmi il mio
nome
e vabbè ho capito saeki la password dei
sex possiamo entrare lì sul profilo di
facebook e scrivere stronzate lega a no
per un pezzo ma posso scrivere può vj fa
vigenti
la vj a me come dovrà un papà vige
sempre a risposte fatemi capire posso
scrivere in una cassaforte si aperto
come come posso scrivere in una
cassaforte cazzi cassaforte un'altra
chiave va beh ma tanto ormai le chiavi o
ormai eccola perfetto c'è ancora l'altra
ci mancano tre poi non posso avere più
chiavi ai computer
ragazzi se c'è facebook la roviniamo
giuro computer che è che è bloccato con
una password che era mickey di chi no
[ __ ]
ma vigera a casa quattro falli gela casa
4 credo che fosse il campo a nello rega
che la roba orribile per ok chi è
entrato hulk chi cazzo è questo chi sei
non so chi tu sia ma fai l'uomo in
proteggimi bagagli è molto pesante se mi
lascia entrare lo porterò per lei va
bene grazie molto gentile metti dove
vuoi da sei tele vidal cazzo ovi
proteggi che ancora meglio vorrei
ringraziarti come la ringraziamo signora
ma guarda come vuoi basta che non ci sia
è la madonna che prendo questa
quell'angolo della free endzone braga
così se nasce editrice vista takamura è
fantastico conoscevi mi sa se chi si la
conoscevo e mia zia era mia zia mi
dispiace per la tua perdita quando c'è
la nipote di vista se chi non le so che
è molto chiara mi6 bisogno stai
tranquillo che non passeranno cinque
minuti però avrò bisogno di a meno
grazie mille per la tua disponibilità
ciao friends on stronzo sembrava carino
mi sembrava carino sta mica ho già
capito è lui il bastardo
sono convinto che vanta zia se dobbiamo
fare come l'altra notte ti prendo a
schiaffi te lo dico d'anticipo proprio
che cazzo è giorno 2 madonna che bell
inizio di giornata di merda e lunedì
ragazzi si vede dall'inizio gli ho un
paio di cosette appena gli rispondo sì
minchia di re anche gli schiaffi e temi
dintorni roba da urli questo è il chiodo
ragazzi concluso fine episodio dopo
questa prima questo primo episodio di
stalking a livello estremo era da un
pezzo lega che non facciamo un rpg
horror quindi spero che vi stia piacendo
è comunque è una cosa un po nuova perché
erano era da un botto che non ne faccio
uno voglio continuano le prossime
pisodio fatemi sapere se volete che lo
continui lasciato mi piace perché se non
stanno attiverà un tizio di zombie a
cercarvi e uccidervi cosa se questo
video è piaciuta certo momento mi piace
anche la pace di facebook e come non i
video trascrizione so se questi
dischetti diavolo prossimo vito e la
ragazza